its very name stoicism comes from the
Greek term stoa po which means painted
porch and refers to a literal porch that
stood right next to the agura or
Marketplace in Athens it was here in the
middle of the bustling City Life that
the first stoics would gather to
purposely engage with the public the
founder of stoicism is often said to be
Zeno of kitum a figure originally from
Cyprus who is said to have studied
philosophy under the famous cynic
philosopher Kates and there are indeed
some significant similarities between
stoicism and the cynics but Zeno is also
said to have studied with other
philosophers and the school that he
started was unique and original in very
important ways while Zeno is considered
the founder the fundamental features of
the philosophy of course developed over
time with his successors